si on prend par exemple le bilan de la
banque centrale européenne et il a
augmenté de 24 % en un an si vous voulez
de de fin 2010 9 à fin 2020 on a 24 %
d'augmentation du bilan si on prend
maintenant les actifs de ce qu'on
appelle l'eurosystème c'est à dire le
réseau des banques centrales de tous les
pays et qui font partie de la zone euro
là c'est encore plus spectaculaire
le ces actifs étaient de l'ordre de 2600
milliards d'euros en 2019 ils sont en
fin 2020 à
3700 milliards autrement dit un
accroissement de 40 % et si maintenant
on sort d'europe et qu'on regarde aux
états unis c'est encore plus fou si vous
voulez le bilan de la réserve fédérale
est pas fait de 4200 1 milliards à plus
de 7000 milliards autrement dit un
accroissement de 72% en moins de sept
mois donc oui il y a bien eu des
injections massives
du point de vue monétaire
on termine avec un point sur l'économie
les bourses mondiales sur sont sur un
petit nuage
elle voit deux elle vole de record en
record notamment à paris avec un cac40 à
plus de 7000 points du jamais vu depuis
la bulle internet plus haut historique
aussi à wall street et au dessus des
indices boursiers sur le bitcoin alors
tout va t'il si bien sûr la planète
finance comment expliquer une telle
euphorie des bourses elles ne sont elles
pas déconnectée de l'économie réelle on
en parle tout de suite avec un
l'économiste jacques sapir dans l'édito
rico
[Musique]
bonsoir à jacques alors l'euphorie
actuelle des bourses n'est-elle pas mal
scène alors que l'inflation monte que
les banques centrales se prépare à être
moins généreuse un oui on peut dire
effectivement qu'il y à un élément
malsain dans cette espèce d'envolée des
bourses on voit d'ailleurs que
l'inflation est aussi en train de monter
et généralement c'est deux choses qui ne
font pas spécialement bon ménage alors
oui vous avez raison les bourses se
prépare dans les différents pays a
adopté des programmes de réduction de
leurs achats voire de hausse des taux
d'intérêt mais au delà on peut se
demander si justement ces bourses sont
pas devenus elle même les prisonnières
des marchés financiers qu'elles sont
censées justement surveiller jacques est
ce que les bourses sont sont elles
réellement le foriic 1 ah oui alors la
samantha tout à fait alors prenons le
cas d'abord du cac 40 de la bourse de
paris
il vient de passer à la fin de la
semaine dernière un record historique
les 7000 points qui n'avaient pas
atteint d'ailleurs à son plus haut en
2000 au moment de la bulle internet et
il continue encore aujourd'hui à être
au-dessus des 7000 points même chose
pour le dow jones à wall street à new
york le dow jones est au dessus de 36000
oui il est évident que actuellement nous
avons des plus hauts historiques pour
les bourses alors justement comment
l'expliquer à quoi c'est dû alors il ya
une explication d'ordre réel il faut le
savoir parce que bien sûr avec la crise
de l'aco vide certaines entreprises ont
tiré leur épingle du jeu les gaffes à un
google amazon etc ont fait de très gros
profits ont vu leurs dividendes
augmenter et donc il est normal que leur
valorisation mais maintenant il faut
quand même dire que le reste de la côte
a quand même connu une une année et
demie nettement plus compliquée que ce
qui s'est passé pour ces entreprises et
donc on voit bien que ce ne sont pas
simplement les éléments réels qui
propulse les bourses à ses sommets en
réalité il y à bien la politique des
banques centrales les banques centrales
qui ont baissé très fortement les taux
d'intérêt qui n'arrêtent pas d'injecter
de l'argent dans l'économie et ça
évidemment ça provoque l'équivalent
d'une bulle boursière et dans quelles
proportions
alors ça c'est des proportions qui sont
assez considérables si on prend par
exemple le bilan de la banque centrale
européenne et il a augmenté de 24 % en
un an si vous voulez de de fin 2010 9 à
fin 2020 on a 24 % d'augmentation du
bilan si on prend maintenant les actifs
de ce qu'on appelle l'eurosystème c'est
à dire le réseau des banques centrales
de tous les pays et qui font partie de
la zone euro là c'est encore plus
spectaculaire et le ces actifs étaient
de l'ordre de 2600 milliards d'euros en
2019 ils sont en fin 2020 à
3500 milliards autrement dit un
accroissement de 40 % et si maintenant
on sort d'europe et qu'on regarde aux
états unis c'est encore plus fou si vous
voulez le bilan de la réserve fédérale
est pas fait de 4200 milliards à plus de
7000 milliards autrement dit un
accroissement de 72% en moins de sept
mois donc oui il y a bien eu des
injections massives
du point de vue monétaire ces injections
justement massive de monnaie dans
l'économie est ce que c'est soutenable
alors c'est bien justement la raison
qu'on se pose et même chose par exemple
pour les taux d'intérêt alors
aujourd'hui on n'a déjà plus banques
centrales qui ont annoncé leur volonté
de réduire leur politique de rachat des
titres de commencer à faire remonter les
taux d'intérêt nous avons la banque du
canada la banque centrale du canada ça
c'était à la fin du mois d'octobre début
novembre
c'est la réserve fédérale elle même qui
a annoncé qu'il y aurait probablement de
hausse de taux dans l'année 2022 et qui
a annoncé un resserrement de ses rachats
d'actions la banque d'angleterre elle
même a fait des annonces dans ce sens et
puis il ya déjà des banques qui ont
sauté le pas un il faut quand même le
dire en particulier
la banque de corée bon bref il y a
globalement aujourd'hui une forme de
tendance générale à la restriction
monétaire plus ou moins accéléré suivant
les zones et en europe alors lequel
l'europe justement est intéressant parce
que on voit bien que l'europe étant un
petit peu en retard par rapport aux
états unis pour la reprise madame
christine lagarde lors de la dernière
réunion qui a eu lieu à la bce a
maintenu le discours en disant non il
est trop tôt pour parler d'un
resserrement et elle a dit que
fondamentalement les taux ne bougerait
pas tant que l'inflation de manière
durable ne dépasserait pas l'objectif et
je rappelle que cet objectif est de 2%
sauf que sauf que l'inflation est déjà à
4,6 pour cent en allemagne à 3 % en
moyenne dans la zone euro donc ils sont
1 nettement au dessus comme l'allemagne
et donc on voit bien qu'il va y avoir
des pressions d'ores et déjà la semaine
dernière et au début de cette semaine la
presse allemande a très violemment
attaqué madame lagarde l'appelant à
madame d'inflation d'ailleurs
l'attaquant de manière pas très élégante
il faut le dire et donc on voit bien que
la banque centrale européenne ne pourra
pas maintenir sa politique elle sera
obligée et probablement ça sera annoncé
lors de la prochaine réunion qui doit
avoir lieu au début du mois de décembre
elle va être obligée d'annoncer beaucoup
plus vite des formes de restriction de
sa politique d'achats elle doit en
particulier décidé de la poursuite du
programme ppp le programme de rachat qui
était consécutif à la crise a pandémique
a normalement ce programme devait se
terminer au mois de mars 2022 il n'est
pas impossible qu'il se termine plus
vite que prévu et de ce point de vue là
on doit avoir vraiment les yeux rivés
sur l'inflation en allemagne est ce que
vous pensez jacques les banques
centrales pourraient bientôt changer de
stratégie oui je pense que samantha que
c'est absolument inévitable allant
pauvres pour plusieurs raisons nous
avons tout d'abord cette inflation qui
est peut être transitoire mais combien
d'années mettons sous le mot transitoire
il est clair qu'elle se poursuivra en
2022 nous avons les bulles d'actifs nous
avons un l'immobilier qui montent
beaucoup
nous avons le bit coin qui monte lui
aussi beaucoup avec l'ensemble des
autres crypto monnaie et il y a un
problème aussi d'inégalités sociales
parce qu'on sait très bien que les
personnes qui possèdent des titres
boursiers c'est grosso modo le 1 pour
cent le plus riche au mieux le d pour
cent le plus riche de la population donc
ce sont eux qui bénéficient d'une
certaine manière de ces hausses de tout
le reste de la population n'en
bénéficient pas et par contre subi une
inflation et puis il ya un troisième
point on voit aujourd'hui et ça a été
très clair par exemple dans l'allocution
café emmanuel macron le 9 novembre on
voit qu'on est en train de s'orienter
vers une politique
d'investissement extrêmement important
et d'une certaine manière cette
politique est bien elle va nécessiter
des engagements de l'état de plus en
plus important là encore il faut
entendre ce qu a dit emmanuel macron le
marché ne peut pas tout l'état va devoir
intervenir et donc les banques centrales
vont devoir s'adapter à cette nouvelle
situation est à ce point de vue là
élaboré une nouvelle stratégie mais le
faire sans casser la croissance actuelle
et c'est peut-être ça le principal défi
qu'elles ont devant l'autel merci
beaucoup à vous jacques sapir pour cette
analyse merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine